hello the internet i'm gav i'm dan we're
the slow-mo guys now i'm already sway
i've got my shortest shorts on and some
flip-flops on it's also june
oh
something's uh something's all coming
back ah
now you may be thinking
aren't these two idiots a little bit too
old to be farting around on youtube with
giant balloons and to that i say
i think we were too old the first time
we did it
so no yeah yeah but no i mean either
that or you're never too old
yeah maybe maybe you're never too old
yeah let's see how long we can do giant
balloon june videos
um in this video we're going to create a
dance sandwich between two giant
balloons is that how physics works
i don't think so
yeah it will either make a successful
damage or i'll die trying i guess yeah
ideally the first one ideally the first
one you know we'll take the second as a
as a backup all right i'll start filling
them up let's get the hose gonna film
this in 4k pretty wide lens and
well slightly worried the camera's going
to get washed away to be honest i feel
like i've watched you do this
quite a lot of times it feels weird not
being inside it though
yeah yeah i found that most of the time
recently i've been inside
[Music]
also i remember i've been squashed by
one of these before and it wasn't
pleasant so either way i'm not gonna
have a great time yeah that was the
trampoline with your legs getting
snapped the wrong way
yeah yeah funny thing when you sit on
something that does that so do you
reckon i should go like this or on my
back on your back on the back yeah and i
think what the plan should be is
whichever one pops first
definitely the bottom one uh just pop
the top one immediately and we'll try
and get both in the same slow-mo clip
all right
i'll try and not let the fact that i'm
being squashed to death uh distract me
from the fact that i've got to pop a
balloon yeah yeah current temps
no idea what that is in uh old-fashioned
that's getting close enough to lie down
on i think i think so do you know when
they have like lambings
and the legs come out first yeah might
be a two-person job
oh
yeah pull ladder
oh
god
we're probably the most experienced
with giant balloons we still don't know
what we're doing but usually the knot is
my neck
just gonna go for a straight tie then
this is so hard all right it's time to
uh fill the second yeah one thing i have
to take my mic off because i'm going to
get soaked hopefully so just start a
voicemail during this drop
you're gonna overheat
on it
i'll do probably
[Laughter]
it's pretty comfy is it no
do you have your safety fork
oh i need that catch me
all right i'm gonna turn the tap on okay
so you're basically just gonna have to
stab the top one as soon as you go down
i think so yeah
let's go let's stab myself for the
thought do you like your career
yeah when you say an encourage sure it's
forms what do you do is what's up what's
your profession
i'll just send them this celebration
i wonder if they'll put my premiums up
or not
it's like flop down the sidelit
yeah you have to keep the bean on you
it's now it's now just a giant kidney
bean
you look like a kid with his bean in bed
it's getting heavy now
i'm sinking further and further into
this bottom one it's actually not
uncomfortable
no that's that's not uncomfortable not
particularly the only uncomfortable part
is my neck
because it's like kind of not i have to
like float it it's like a stress
position for my neck it's cooling me
quite nicely though
you wouldn't know it was 35 degrees
there you are
[Laughter]
not helpful it's like teasing me
it's like i can smell a steak but i
can't eat it
that is considerable
i wasn't ready for that
it looks like an animal got like a wild
animal got out of its collar and you
have to quickly stab it
you're like okay
[Music]
you just look like you're having the oh
look at what oh
look how quickly i start falling you're
already getting plummeted
there's the fork you're going for the
fork i'm just trying to grab it back i
was just casually holding it and then
posh look at the
the tear
moving with all the water coming over oh
the blue one popped oh it did it popped
immediately
it popped but it wasn't so full that it
all went it's like this bit isn't
popping because it's just contained and
slowly deflating oh and you're like
so i basically just popped nothing
i just popped nothing
it honestly looked like you were trying
to stab a crocodile that just evaded you
come here
feel like ah where's the fall
you've done well to get it yeah i knew
it back did i actually get it in time
for a shot
no
oh
oh
because it already popped so i was like
i'm triggering it so we don't miss the
beginning as i triggered it
so we got like i was just getting the
crocodile oh boy i wonder if it's worth
if we do it again and we'll on top we'll
have a five foot balloon
so it's more likely to go so it's more
bulbous and under more pressure so that
when it does go it all goes and you're
not there having to then stab a just an
evading balloon such a weird sight it's
like something that lady gaga would wear
to her
i think this is proper met garlic yeah
yeah
now filling the second balloon
sagging quite a bit whoa
this one's saggier is that good that
means there's less in it right i think
so yeah i think that's a good thing oh i
need my fork
all right emergency fork
[Laughter]
never worth it a little bit of
excitement for us isn't it
so warm
a lot of your audio is bouncing off the
underneath of this no scrumping side and
it's gonna sound so weird this one's got
a little bit of a
little knob
this might be the first time i've ever
sunburned the bottom of my chin
rarely seen by the sun that i'm trying
to hold the fork much more firmly this
time
you look like you were hiding inside a
cake but it got too hot
never looked better
it looks like two mr men on a sleepover
well i can't wait for it to pop now
oh
you can tell in your voice that you're
feeling the strain isn't this good
oh man
it's getting unmanageable
oh it just got bigger just then yeah i'm
supposed to be presenting a video right
now i can't no no don't worry about it
i'll i'll host you just be in between
two bullets
let me just stand here a bit witty
comments for you
yeah i'm gonna have a fat neck
which one went first oh i think it was
the bottom one was it i think so it was
it looked i blinked and everything was
gone
[Laughter]
flip it's not it's not uncomfortable
though
like after it goes yeah it's nice it's
nice yeah
you look like you're like you're in
agony i am it's so hard you've given
birth oh look like a pepsi logo
not sponsored by pepsi you can so easily
imagine your body being the blue balloon
a fly that's just going over the top of
you that's like i know what's going to
happen here i'm getting the heck out of
it go get it
it's got my weight which is whoa
it worked it popped through the air
bubble so really like it came from under
your leg and went
it was much faster moving through the
air bubble than through the water i've
not seen that before in all the times
you've been doing it the air bubble you
never really see it like that i don't
think we've ever had a rip go over the
air but we've definitely seen them and
then they it sort of slides over it but
i don't think we've ever seen the rip go
through it that's cool that's really
cool
you're immediate look at your legs
immediately sinking into the water just
reasserting itself straight away that's
probably your your ass hitting the floor
there oh
yeah but exactly like the other one
i still had a lot of way to go that well
look at it shrinking away you can see
down into it is it shrinking weird yeah
look at that lovely bit there it's just
leaving a big shell of water there
so crystal clear you can see my
shortcuts through it
and what's on the other side of the
crystal clear
and then once again look at my foot this
looks so weird if you just take this
image you know when mr bean just comes
landing down on the in the beam of light
it's like if mr bean like missed and
landed in a puddle ah because what like
oh you could see me land i'm looking
like a fish looks like a poured a fish
out of a bucket it doesn't hit the floor
and it's like flapping around yeah it
really
your face
oh man
you don't know where you are
your eyes look bloodshot like
i'm like what's happened
i think to make up for that excessive
water usage i uh won't run the
sprinklers for the last six years six
years yep so this is our blauen
blauenballon
blou and bello
balon
and our red one
is it luft
luftballon yeah look actually it wasn't
left it was vassa vassa this one seems
fine i could probably blow this back up
again see if you can
it seems fine i reckon you could do this
again this is reusable
yeah
that's still intact mostly yeah we can
redo that
put it back in the box we can reuse this
and put it back you can still see the
size difference between the
six foot and the five foot it's amazing
how much
this much difference makes an extra foot
when they're done yeah well you know
they say
you know never say never
yeah i never think i'll get bored of
that
that's fair yeah yeah i agree with that
i think there's nothing better than
it being hot in june just sandwiched
between two water balloons and cooling
off what a way to relax
now i've gotta really wreck our brains
and think about what we're gonna do next
june um if it helped that we missed a
couple of tunes
there were a couple of non-dunes that
happened yeah but also we haven't
stacked up more it's not like really new
[Applause]
i think this was 2020s
oh really
i had to scroll back in the list but we
got it done and now we have a whole year
to
come up with another variant
i'm already looking forward to it
actually can we just do another one now
if we had the budget
what if
we took me up in a plane
right
got me in a water balloon
i have a parachute on
in the water balloon right right i'm in
a giant water balloon yeah
falling down so you're in zero g like
you're sweating at it trying to pop it
and all that i'm just in it yeah with it
i'm just like
and i have to pop it
and then pull my parachute after like a
few seconds of the water disappear and i
assume i'm
also with the parachute you're diving
you're coming out as well just with the
phantom yeah
if you have 18 million dollars please
show us on a postcard thank you very
much for watching make sure you
subscribe if you like slow-mo and why
don't you watch this video
i'm just gonna press best for viewer
because uh
unless you've got a specific video that
they should watch do you think
um an old one oh what about the first
giant balloon because uh
it's it's approaching 200 million views
i want to do the one where i'm in the
balloon okay all right
uh well why don't you watch one of these
this one
you could just choose which side that
you put the video i just do two of the
same way